visite tout à l'heure de vladimir
poutine à sébastopol en crimée à
l'occasion de la journée de l'unité
nationale dans le même temps le chef du
kremlin a participé à une réunion en
biseau conférence du conseil suprême de
l'état de l'union de la russie et de la
biélorussie plus de précisions tout de
suite avec notre correspondant à moscou
anthony clairement
antoine que faut-il retenir de ce
déplacement de vladimir poutine
oui la russie et la biélorussie viennent
de faire un nouveau pas vers un
rapprochement entre les deux pays malgré
le format de vidéo conférences les
présidents russe et biélorusse sont
signé un décret qui a pour ambition de
prolonger de renforcer la coopération
entre les deux pays et ce dans de
nombreux domaines 28 programmes
sectoriels ont été identifiés on peut
citer les secteurs agroalimentaire
nucléaire bancaire du transport mais
aussi le domaine militaire l'objectif
affiché prospérité stabilité sécurité
écoutez
jb says âgées famille régnant à chaque
machine granit la mission de créer un
climat de stabilité et de sécurité à nos
frontières extérieures devient d'une
importance particulière
nous avons l'intention de résister
ensemble à toute tentative d'ingérence
dans les affaires intérieures de nos
états souverains et la russie bien sûr
continuera à fournir une assistance au
peuple biélorusse frère il n'y a aucun
doute là dessus l' état unifié
renforcera la coopération en matière
d'intégration ce qui améliorera en fin
de compte le niveau de vie et le
bien-être de nos citoyens et bien sûr
nous continuerons à poursuivre le
travail de manière déterminée pour que
l' état unifié soit doté de nouveaux
contenus permettant de développer
pleinement son potentiel de création
pour nos inscrits y aussi ceux des
ténors automne ça
voulait dire poutine en a profité pour
envoyer un message aux autres pays dans
le contexte de crise de l'énergie que
l'europe traverse actuellement la
biélorussie qui entretient donc de
bonnes relations avec la russie et qui a
conclu des contrats d'approvisionnement
sur le long terme achète son gaz 7 8
voire 9 ou 10 fois moins cher que sur
les marchés financiers européens vingt
ans après ses débuts l'union de la
russie et de la biélorussie continue
donc sa construction et entendre les
différents intervenants de cette réunion
une étape importante vient d'être
franchie aujourd'hui
merci anthony claireaux pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de moscou